comment lundi dernier maître on peut
décider de le mettre en prison et hier
de le remettre en liberté
parce qu'il y a eu un élément nouveau
c'est quoi c'est que je pense que il y a
une expertise médicale qui a dû être
ordonnée par le juge d'instruction et
que l'expertise médicale a dû dire que
son état de santé était incompatible
avec la détention ou une expertise
médicale ou un certificat médical du
médecin qui s'occupe de Pierre Palmade
et qui a dit que il était impossible que
celui-ci demeure en détention parce que
son état de santé était incompatible
est-ce que ça veut dire que Pierre Palma
est très bien défendu aussi oui il est
très bien défendu absolument donc
l'avocat très bien fait l'avocat de
Pierre Palmade c'est mettre Céline lacet
a fait très bien elle a fait un travail
de très bon professionnel d'accord et en
effet la difficulté dans ce dossier
lorsqu'on la difficulté dans ce dossier
c'est que
on a quelqu'un qui a qui qui est mise en
examen pour homicide involontaire et
avec des circonstances aggravantes qui
sont donc notamment l'usage de
stupéfiants c'est cet élément cette
homicide involontaire qui est sur un
enfant donc ça reste encore à établir
puisque nous savons que la première
expertise a dit que a priori ne pouvait
pas se prononcer pour savoir si le fœtus
était vivant ou non donc va se poser la
question de l'homicide involontaire en
revanche on sait que il y a eu des
blessés qui sont gravement touchés du
fait de la collision et Monsieur Palmade
conduisait alors qu'il était sous
l'emprise des stupéfiants ça c'est le
dossier donc normalement il aurait dû
aller en détention provisoire alors
voilà aujourd'hui le contrôle judiciaire
de Pierre Palma est assorti de plusieurs
obligations interdiction de quitter le
territoire français interdiction d'aller
en Seine-et-Marne alors c'était c'est où
le l'accident a eu lieu
interdiction de conduire interdiction de
fréquenter les deux hommes qui se
trouvaient dans sa voiture au moment de
l'accident obligation de se soumettre un
traitement à des fins de désintoxication
donc voilà donc c'est tout ça et tous
les dire ajouter un truc la
Seine-et-Marne parce que la famille des
victimes originaire
tu sais pas s'il y a juste une
instruction a demandé la levée du
placement en détention provisoire pour
raison médicale et le parquet de Melun a
formé un référé des tensions afin de
contester et donc de suspendre cette
décision pour résumer donc en fait c'est
quoi c'est que c'est quoi le parquet
c'est le procureur et le nouveau
procureur de Melun le procureur de Melun
qui lui veut que le gagnant prison oui
et le juge d'instruction lui dit non on
lève le placement en détention
provisoire mettre
ça arrive souvent ça ou pas oui d'accord
personne est remise en liberté par le
par le juge d'instruction comme vous le
dites le procureur fait appel et donc la
procédure sur l'appel sur cette mise en
liberté elle a lieu vendredi prochain
en revanche normalement la personne sort
immédiatement c'est pour ça que le
procureur fait ce qu'on appelle un
référé des tensions en demandant à ce
que la sortie de la personne avant que
l'audience au fond et lieu ne puisse pas
sortir c'est à dire que sa liberté soit
suspendue d'accord et là on a eu et là
ce n'est pas devant la même chambre
c'est devant un seul magistrat un
président qui a décidé de ne pas
suspendre la décision du juge du juge
d'instruction et c'est pour ça que
Monsieur Palmade va comparaître libre à
l'audience de vendredi
il peut y être incarcéré c'est ça mais
alors moi je connais rien maître
c'est qui qui a le dernier mot c'est le
procureur ou le juge d'instruction mais
là ça sera la chambre de l'instruction
qui va se tuer vendredi c'est qui ces
trois magistrats
de la Cour donc moi mais c'est quoi ils
sont ils sont avec qui ils sont avec le
jeu
complètement indépendants avec l'autre
maintenant la difficulté de s'ils disent
c'est eux qui vont décider c'est-à-dire
que le parquet il peut pas dire derrière
non on est flottant non le dernier mot
le dernier mot appartiendra la chambre
de l'instruction
et se baseront sur la vie des médecins
si si tout à l'heure qu'elle est très
bonne avocat il faut aussi dire aussi
les choses elle est pas très bonne
avocat il est vraiment opéré il subit
bien sûr l'opération c'est pas on ne va
pas inventé j'ai déjà eu des dossiers de
ce type où j'ai mené un combat mais mais
de guerrier pour que la personne mon
client puisse sortir j'avais des des
expertises fait par un collège d'experts
en disant que
que technicien extérieur s'il y a cet
élément médical qui dit que Monsieur
Palmade encore une fois un état de santé
qui est incompatible avec la détention
de quel droit elle va se retrouver
pardonnez-moi juste un point on peut il
peut parce que ça ça arrive que cet état
de santé soit considéré comme
incompatible avec la détention sous
réserve 2 alors ce sous réserve 2 ça
peut être tout et n'importe quoi c'est
on peut dire monsieur son état de santé
est incompatible avec les avec la
détention cependant si celui-ci est
placé à l'hôpital de Fresnes puisqu'il
n'y a que celui-ci de de de de de
centres qui qui s'occupe des personnes
qui ont des difficultés de santé si et
bien il a une infirmière 24 heures sur
24 si un médecin est capable de venir
tous les jours pour le consulter et pour
vérifier du quelle est sa situation de
santé sauf que ça ce sont des réserves
qui sont posées par les médecins mais
qui ignorent ce qui se passe en
dépression or en détention ce que je et
ça je je l'affirme il n'existe pas les
moyens matériels et humains pour gérer
le cas de santé de personnes qui sont
gravement atteintes alors c'est ça le
postulat mais le procureur il a le
dossier donc pourquoi il insiste pour le
mettre en détention alors que il a
priori de ce que vous nous dites c'est
que si son dossier médical et béton
vendredi 9h le juge d'instruction va ils
vont donner raison juste instruction
donc pourquoi il se bat autant
pour le mettre en détention c'est une
très bonne question je pense que non non
mais vraiment parce que en fait
non mais c'est vrai parce que je pense
que c'est lié à la gravité de de d'effet
et aux troubles à l'ordre public et je
pense que c'est un élément qui est
déterminant pour conduire aujourd'hui le
ministère public a considéré que
bien état de santé mais que cette santé
il peut être pris en considération si
celui-ci est placé en détention à
l'hôpital de Fresnes ce qui est une
grave erreur mais le procureur lui pense
que que il y a les moyens matériels et
humains de le faire et que par rapport à
l'opinion publique au trouble public
causés par cette personne-là on ne peut
pas accepter que celui-ci continue entre
guillemets à être libre avec l'accident
qu'il a causé c'est ça le l'équation
c'est un procureur qui est arrivé à
Melun quatre jours quatre jours avant
l'accident c'est son premier dossier
c'est un procureur réputé pour sa
sévérité il a travaillé à la police
judiciaire il a travaillé sur l'anti
terrorisme c'est son premier dossier il
veut marquer le coup lui il juge qu'il a
un dossier qui est accablant pour le
moment il a été retoqué ce matin et on
verra vendredi si les rotokines deuxième
fois mais lui il ne démarre pas depuis
le début non mais bon après il fait son
boulot
le procureur fait son métier mais bien
il relève à peine encore que il pourrait
aussi parce que encore une fois sous
toutes les réserves parce que j'ignore
ce qu'il y a vraiment dans le dossier à
part ce qu'il en a été dit dans la
presse mais encore une fois si on
considère que la détention de serait
possible malgré l'état de santé de
Monsieur Palmade qui n'est pas entre
guillemets une un fake qui est réel ok
que celui-ci pourrait recevoir les soins
nécessaires à l'hôpital de Fresnes on se
fiche du monde c'est impossible il y a
une guerre entre le procureur et le juge
d'instruction
rarement une série là le juge et le proc
c'était la guerre entre nous